※この動画は閲覧注意です※
※狂気に満ちております※
皆さん
「青べ～」というガム、ご存知でしょうか
こういうの
なんか駄菓子屋さんとかで見たことある人いません
でしょうか
「青べ～緑べ～ガム」
「な～んとッ口の中が青になるガム」
「これがうわさのビックリガム！」
「このガムをかんでみんなをおどろかそう！！」
この「青べ～緑べ～」何かといいますと
食べると
口の中が
真っ青になるガムでございます
食べたことある人いると思うんですけども
・・・
すごいんすよｗ
今、舌赤いんですけども
１回、とりあえず１個食べてみましょう
青だけ食べます
見た目はもう普通のガムなんすよね
普通のガムなのに
食べると衝撃な色になってしまいます
いただきますッ！
うまい棒「 まず俺らを先に食えや 」
※早送り
ｸﾁｬｸﾁｬｸﾁｬｸﾁｬｸﾁｬｸﾁｬｸﾁｬｸﾁｬｸﾁｬｸﾁｬｸﾁｬｸﾁｬｸﾁｬｸﾁｬｸﾁｬｸﾁｬ
うん、１個ガム食べてみました
口の中を見てみましょう
えへっ！？
なっ！？
なんで！？
はい、というわけであの
１個食べたら
１個食べて
なるんだったら
100個食べると
すごい色になるんじゃないか？
いやもうワンチャン
ずっと青いんじゃないか？
やっぱりね、俺はね
あの、人と同じなの嫌なんすよ！
というわけで、皆赤いじゃないですか
舌の色
僕ぐらい青くていいんじゃないかと思いまして
100個食ったら
舌がワンチャン永続的に
青になれるんじゃないかと思いまして
今回「青べ～ガム」だけを
緑べ～「解せぬ」
100個
連続で噛んでみたいと思います
その結果、口の中が何色になるか
（青に決まってんだろ）
やってみましょう！
じゃあいただきます！
もうガンガンいきますからね
うまい棒「何が『ガンガンいきますからね』だ！
※早送り
うまい棒「まずは俺たちを食えよ！」
うまい棒「おいもやし！ふざけんなもやし！」
※早送り
ああ･･･
ああっ！
うまい棒「そうなるだろうと思ったぜ！」
※早送り
うまい棒「分かったら俺たちを食え！」
うまい棒「この浮気者！」
※早送り
はい、というわけでとりあえず
10個
噛んでみました
10個食べたら口はこんな感じに
なりま舌
んっ！
うわっ！
え、待ってやばい
待って、歯が！
歯が！歯が！
待って、うわ～！
歯！歯！
※グロ注意※グロ注意※グロ注意
うえええ！！
えええっっっっへえっへえっへえｗｗｗｗ
はっはっはっはっはっはｗｗ
はぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ･････････
待ってこれどうすんの？
10個でこのレベルでしょ？
待ってやばい
俺終わるかもしんないこれ
やっば！
いや俺これ戻んないかもしんないけど
とりあえず100個食べます
うまい棒「お前はいつだってそうだ！」
※早送り
うまい棒「大体お前大食い企画何回目だよ！」
うまい棒「マンネリ気味だぞ！もうちょい捻れや！」
※早送り
うう･･･
うううう･･･
うううううう！
うまい棒「なんで俺らを先に食わねえんだ！」
※早送り
うまい棒「うまい棒ナメんなよお前！」
うまい棒「俺らが本気出したら怖いんだぞ！」
※早送り
うまい棒「わたしの戦闘力は530000です」
はい、えー
30個食べました
お、お口の様子を見てみましょう
やばいもうはみ出てんな･･･
ああ･･･
※グロ注意※グロ注意※グロ注意
ああ･･･！
ああ～やばいなこれ･･･
ああ･･･
あの、さっきより明らかに悪化してますね･･･
なんかさっきは･･･なんかもう
青！って感じだったんですけど
今もう･･･
（青！！！って感じ）
こｗｗこｗ治んのこれ！？
どうすんのこれ！
治んなかったらどうしてくれんの！？
あのなんか全然美味しいんすけどお･･･
顎がキツい！
ガム噛むの
僕だって今ガム30個噛んだわけですからね！
キツいキツい！
もう顎が痛すぎてちょっとやばいっす
あともう70個頑張ってみようと思います･･･
では･･･
うまい棒「お前には無理だぜえっ！」
※早送り
うまい棒「もう諦めて俺たちを先に食えよ！」
うまい棒「そうした方が楽だと思うぜ！」
※早送り
うまい棒「おいっ！聞こえないのか！」
顎が痛い！
ガム噛みすぎて･･･！
鼻が痛い(空耳)
はい、というわけで50個食べました
あの･･･
ガムの噛みすぎでホントに頭が痛いです
やばい！顎も！頭も痛い！
では、見てみましょう･･･！
はい
えへぇへ
もうなんか、ベロじゃなくて
唇が青くなってきましたね
（あれ？さっきと変わんなくね？）
えええ！？
これ治んのかな～！
さすがに30~50の変化は少ないっすね
もう結構上限に達したのでしょうか
ただ分かんないのはこっからです
残り50個くらいあると思うんで
残り50個でどのような変化が出るのか
このまま一気に100までいってみようと思います･･･
では！
うまい棒「はじめよ･･･お前の勇姿は伝わった･･･」
※早送り
うまい棒「今回は黙って見守ることにするぜ･･･」
うまい棒「お前ならいけるぞ！はじめ！」
※早送り
うまい棒「頑張るんだ！負けるんじゃないぞ！」
（！？）
うまい棒「期待した俺がバカだったぜ」
「へえっ･･･ｗ」
「やっば！何やってんすか！？」
青べ～食べすぎたんや･･･
「はっはｗｗ」
「やばいっすよ、やばいよー･･･」
【ED】
はい、というわけで
すいません
あの･･･
50っっっっっ個からもう頑張って食ってみたんすけど
あのお･･･途中から･･･
変化がありませんでした
多分、50個くらい食うと多分
青べ～の限界まで達して
もう、変化が無くなってきたんで･･･
塗りました･･･
ｻｱｾﾝｼﾀｯ!
これ･･･これ落ちんのかな口の中･･･？